hello in this video we'll talk about
green fluorescence protein and its
application in biomedical research
so green fluorescence protein or gfp is
a protein that exhibits bright green
fluorescence
if we expose it to a blue or ultraviolet
light
this green fluorescence protein has a
beta barrel like structure and it was
discovered from the
jellyfish aquarium
victoria and now this is the pillar of
biomedical research especially people
who are working with cell biology
molecular biology etc in this video
we'll talk about
several applications of gfp and green
fluorescence protein let me tell you
apart from green fluorescence protein
scientists have now generated other
colored
fluorescence proteins such as citrine
m cherry
m turquoise and many more
now let's say we are a biomedical
researcher and we want to know that
where a particular protein of interest
in this case protein x is localized
inside the cell
so here is our protein x and we want to
know where it is localized we can tag
protein x with a gfp and this is
possible with the help of recombinant
dna technology here we will be
cloning the coding region for protein x
along with the gfp sequence and then
clone it into an expression vector and
then translate the expression vector
inside a cell where we want to see its
subcellular localization
so when this particular protein would be
transcribed we can see the fluorescence
in this case we can see all the
fluorescence are coming from the nucleus
that means protein x is localized in the
nucleus so this is one type of
application
but what's the big deal about it we can
use
immunohistochemistry to do the same
we can detect the presence of this
protein in the nucleus or cytoplasm
using
a particular antibody against it so
what's the big deal about it the big
deal
would be understood if we try to
understand
um the cellular dynamics
let's say we want to study
vesicular trafficking inside the cell
and it's a dynamic process happening in
real time so we cannot rely on frozen
snapshot right
in this case let's say we have a
particular vesicle that we want to track
we can level this vesicle with gfp let's
say we have tagged rab with gfp wrap is
linked with the vesicles so the vesicles
would be also labeled now wherever these
vesicles go
we can see
the fluorescence there so overall we can
track the fuel sense to understand the
position of this vesicle in real time
and this makes a lot of sense in terms
of neurotransmitter containing vesicle
trafficking so inside the neuron
neurotransmitters are generated in the
cell body and they are trafficked
towards the synapse and in this process
they have to travel a long distance from
the cell body to the synapse
so the long track of microtubule works
like a highway where kinesins
take these vesicles and move it to the
synapses now if we label these vesicles
by gfp let's say a particular protein or
a cargo is inside this vesicle and we
level that cargo so these vesicles are
now gfp tag and now we can understand
their
motion and their movement in real time
we can understand the movement time
skills movement kinetics the movement
direction and many other informations
now let's try to understand what could
be the
other applications of this approach it
turns out that gfp reporters can help us
to study
tissue specific gene expression
how is that possible let's say we have a
expression vector here we have a
particular promoter for genex
and instead of the gene body sequence we
have the gfp sequence we can transfect
it into different cell types let's say
epithelial cell a neuronal cell and a
fibroblast
now if we see let's say gfp fluorescence
from fibroblasts and the epithelial cell
and not from the neuron that
instantly tells us that this particular
promoter is active in epithelial and
fibroblast cells not in neurons
so tissue specific gene expression
profiling can be done with gfp based
reporters
also if we want to level different parts
of the cell we can use it by
gfp
so with the gfp sequence if we tag a
membrane tether such as mcd8 it would
mark the membrane if we attach a nuclear
localization signal or a mitochondrial
localization signal it would go to the
nucleus or the mitochondria and thereby
highlighting that particular structure
which can be studied in real time let's
say we want to study the fusion dynamics
of mitochondria so we have labeled the
mitochondria by attaching gfp with a
mitochondrial localization signal and
now the mitochondrias are highlighted in
green
now we can track the dynamics of
mitochondrial fusion in real time
also we can track cell migration in real
time if we tag a particular cell with
gfp in this example this cell is moving
through this tissue space in real time
and we can track it with live microscopy
we can also understand how
we can understand how strong is a
promoter
or the strength of the promoter can be
determined so this is a particular
promoter region and this is the gene
body so from the promoted region there
would be transcription right so we can
take this particular promoter region and
instead of the gene body we can put a
gfp sequence that is our fluorescent
reporter now looking at the gfp
fluorescence we can understand the
strength of the promoter let me tell you
how we have two promoters promoter a and
b
in case of promoter a we see this amount
of transcription happened and promoted
in case of
promoter b we see less transcription
happen
so by looking at the fluorescence and
detecting the fluorescence we can
understand promoter a is way stronger
than the promoter b
so whatever we have to
compare is the overall fluorescence
intensity
now let me tell you that combining the
gfp fluorescence with other
calcium sensor protein one can
use it as a calcium indicator
and track the calcium dynamics inside
the cell in real time and this kind of
tool was developed
by uh
zunishi nakai
in
20 201
so
in this case there is a gfp fluorescent
protein which is generally not
fluorescent and it's kind of like a
scrambled or inactivated form
and it is tagged with a calmodulin
protein which can potentially bind to
calcium and there is a m13 helix from a
myosin
uh light chain kinase now whenever
calcium binds there is a conformational
change and the protein is now
fluorescently
the now the protein is fluorescent
so now we can
look at these fluorescent levels in real
time to understand how calcium
fluctuation takes place for example
whenever the neuron fires the
fluorescent intensity goes up and it
comes down when the fluorescents stop
firing so it's it appears as a proxy for
neural activity
now gfp fluorescence can help us to
understand signaling dynamics how is
that possible let's say in a signaling
pathway the last step or the ultimate
step is
transcription of a target gene and this
is the target gene we can take the
target gene promoter and attach it with
a gfp sequence so it works like a
signaling reporter so whenever the
signaling pathway is on there would be
fluorescence and whenever the signaling
pathway would be off there would be no
fluorescence
generally
this particular gene is
transcribed and this is the readout of
the signaling pathway and we kind of
hacked the signaling readout by using
the promoter for this gene and attaching
a gfp
uh sequence with it so whenever the gfp
is transcribed and translated we can see
fluorescence and we can quantify the
fluorescence to understand the signaling
dynamics in real time
now let's talk about the disadvantages
of this kind of approach so whenever we
attach gfp with a protein it might not
interact with a protein normally so
obviously protein protein interaction
could be hindered
also imagine if protein x is actually an
enzyme which converts this substrate to
a product
attaching gfp might hinder its enzymatic
activity so these are few disadvantages
of this approach
now let's talk about the summary so what
are the
benefits of fluorescence labeling we
found that labeling and tracking of
protein inside the cell can be done real
time labeling of subcellular components
can also be done using this approach
checking strength of a promoter or
studying dynamic processes like
vesicular transport can be done using
gfp tag based approach studying cell
signaling dynamics is also possible and
if it is combined with several sensors
then it can work like a calcium sensor
in and it can report us about neural
activity so i hope this video was useful
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel in
patreon or if you're indian viewer you
can support me via in upi app
my courses are present in academy which
is india's biggest online learning
platform if you wish to take a
subscription you can download the app
and you can use my code ap 10 to get a
10 discount thank you